was passiert eigentlich wenn uns eine
alien botschaft erreicht nichts oder
wird die menschheit ins chaos gestürzt
gerät sie in panik oder die komplette
computer kommunikations infrastruktur
wird zerstört
zwei forscher haben sich jetzt mit allen
möglichen szenarien beschäftigt und ich
kann nur sagen
demnach wird es nicht gut ausgehen also
krieg zum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich hochspannendes science videos
abonniert den kanal
denn nur dann verpasst ihr nichts also
herzlich willkommen losone 7 hawking
warnte davor die kontaktaufnahme mit
alien sie könnten feindselig sein und
unsere spezies vernichten und gegenüber
der schöpfung wäre dieser akt sogar gut
denn im moment hausen wir auf der erde
als gäbe es kein morgen und das im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die
vernichtung der menschheit wäre von
diesem standpunkt aus betrachtet gar
nicht so absurd der klimawandel könnte
damit vielleicht doch noch aufgehalten
werden punkt für die aliens aber so oder
so könnten sie feindselig sein und die
erde für sich haben wollen das ende der
menschheit würde drohen zwei
wissenschaftler haben sich jetzt
erstmals mit etwas vermeintlich viel
harmloseren beschäftigt einer botschaft
von aliens was könnte sie enthalten und
was wären die folgen jeweils
horrorszenario 1 die aliens stiften
panik eine sehr einfache und effektive
methode und wir können uns heute gar
nicht ausmalen welche perfiden
botschaften das sein könnten um eine
massenpanik auszulösen
sie müsste nicht mal stimmen also diese
botschaft allein einmal der ein
grausames szenario beschreibt das dann
nicht einmal eintreten müsste könnte
dann zum tod von milliarden menschen
führen und das ende der menschheit
einläuten lediglich wenn die botschaft
nur an einem ort empfangen werden würde
und die verbreitung in der folge
vermieden werden könnte
nur dann könnte dieses szenario
verhindert werden wenn allerdings die
botschaft gezielt so verbreitet wird
dass möglichst viele menschen erreicht
würden dann wäre die massenpanik nicht
mehr zu verhindern es könnte die
stärkste waffe von aliens gegen die
menschheit sein
sie müssten keinerlei waffen einsetzen
nur unsere psyche zur selbstzerstörung
aktivieren horrorszenario 2
die nachricht enthält computerviren auch
hierfür müssen
vermieden werden dass die botschaft
viele menschen und damit computer
erreicht in dem moment in dem sich ein
solcher virus verbreitet könnten die
folgen grausam sein die komplette
infrastruktur des planeten könnte
zerstört werden mit einem mausklick
verändert werden könnte das nur mit
einer analyse auf dem papier oder mit
einem abgeschotteten computer allerdings
wäre papier zu aufwendig und dass ein
computer wirklich abgeschaltet ist
theoretisch zwar möglich aber kann sehr
einfach umgangen werden und forscher und
forscherinnen weltweit machen immer
wieder auf einen noch anderes problem
aufmerksam mit nachrichten von der erde
aus könnten feindliche aliens überhaupt
erst angelockt werden wer darf solche
nachrichten also aussenden müssen sie
genehmigt werden wer entscheidet darüber
logischer schluss solcher überlegungen
eigentlich muss die menschheit darüber
abstimmen ob solche botschaften
ausgesendet werden dürfen oder nicht die
nasa und viele astrophysiker und
astrobiologen und astrophysikerin und
biologin sind sich sicher dass wir in
den nächsten rund 20 jahren auf ihnen
stoßen werden wie und wo das ist
vollkommen unklar aber schon jetzt gibt
es ja schon ein hinweis dass das
interstellare objekt humor von einer
extraterrestrischen spezies stammen
könnte
das exklusive interview dazu mit dem
entdecker der mysteriösen eigenschaften
des interstellaren objekts harvard
professorin loeb das gibt es im original
auf dem englischen kanal hier dafür
einfach draufklicken und den kanal auch
am besten für solche videopremieren
abonnieren
denn nur dann verpasst ihr garantiert
nichts dafür hier klicken und ansonsten
wir die mal sagen stay tuned co2